Chúnga ngon năng tháng 2, đường lỗ ủng hộ cú bá bảo về chủ quyền và nếc của gia
Đông thời phản đối sửa căn thiệt bố lý từ gắt thế lực bên ngoài
Bây giờ, nó giống trong cuộc gặp dựa ngoại trưởng bương í và ngoại trưởng cú bá bương
Nó Rồi Đi Gainesbury là, và kênh theo đổ ngoại gia Trung Quốc
Ông vương khẳng định bắt kênh sẽ sạm hối trợ cú bá trong khả năng có thể
Trong bối cảnh vií gia tăng sự ad với đảo của các libert này
Nhan ngoại gia Trung Quốc cho biết, hai nước dưới chi của hệ hương ý đã biết
Bởi từ các các cuộc gia sáo của chúng nghĩ ở giáo đảng tổng sản tâm quyền
Fia của bá hoang nghe xe ủng hộ của Trung Quốc và các bạn định phản đối căn thiệt bế bệng ngoài
Sống không chỉ để gặp Washington
Fia có tháng mi của bá liều thang từ tháng trước
Lên quan tự biểu Washington bắt giữ lãnh đạo về nguyên rộn lâu
Đông quyền thân cận của là ha bà nè
Tổng thống mi đường đàn trăm của đã thuốc đầy các bạn pháp nhằm sét mồn cùng dầu của bá
Để người rất nước này vào cảnh thứ như liệu, liện và là phát tặng cao
Rồi quan sát cho rằng chuyển thăm diện ra trong bối cảnh cảnh tránh anh hưởng giữa Trung Quốc và Mỹ
Tản mi là tinh đang giá tăng
Nóc biệt xung quan các tuyến hợp hả chỉ lượng gần tinh đợp bà nè mát